diplomacy the thing that keeps us from
immediately going to war with our
enemies and from telling Lichtenstein
how we really feel
you are a snobby polyp on Switzerland
and they should have you removed
immediately it is a busy time for
diplomacy in the Trump White House what
we've done planning the North Korea
summit weighing what to do about Syria
and a state visit with Makran next week
none of which is helped by the fact that
no one has seen Jared in months where is
Jared how can we make crucial foreign
policy decisions without the White
House's goodest boy and on top of all
that there's actually a massive decision
that Trump has to make just around the
corner the Iran deal is coming up
after months of will he won't he read
her it the nuclear deal is on the
president's mind once again this week as
he faces a May 12th deadline to decide
whether to recertify it there's a
growing consensus that this time around
it may finally be dead once and for all
well that is not a good sign for the
Iran deal because whenever there is a
will he won't he question regarding
Trump you can pretty much guarantee that
he will pick the worst possible option
will he pull the u.s. out of the Paris
Accord he did will he try and ban
Muslims from entering the country he did
when he looked directly into the Sun
during the solar eclipse while pointing
at it as if to say look the Sun he did
of course he did of course he did that
and Trump has made it very clear how he
feels about the Iran deal he's called it
terrible a catastrophe stupid insane
incompetent really sad horrible
horrendous horrible horrible terrible
incompetent and one of the dumbest and
most dangerous misjudgments ever which
is coincidentally also exactly what
Trump writes in Don Junior's birthday
card every year is appropriate and and
those criticisms are just the tip of a
very large iceberg I think it's maybe
the worst deal I've ever seen I think
it's the worst deal I've ever seen
negotiated my number one priority is to
dismantle the disastrous deal with Iran
this is the worst deal we got nothing we
got nothing they have so out negotiated
our people because our people have
babies they have no idea what they're
doing they will find out that if I win
we're not babies there's no more being
babies anymore oh that's right Iran
there's no more
being babies anymore we're done wearing
pull-ups and going tinkle in our Oshkosh
we can put our own store in our Juice
box thank you very much because we are
big boys and we have shoes with laces
and also a bike that has spider-man on
it that our uncle Jim got us for
Christmas because we are big boys and
there's no more being babies anymore no
more look make make no mistake this deal
dying could have huge lasting
consequences which makes it a little odd
that nobody is really paying much
attention to the fact that on May 12th
if Trump doesn't feel like this deal has
been fixed to his liking he may refuse
to waive a key sanction which could
threaten the entire thing so tonight
let's look at the Iran deal what it is
why Trump hates it so much and what's
likely to happen if he kills him to
start it probably would help to know
just a little of the history between the
u.s. and Iran which has been fraught to
put it mildly
here is a ludicrously brief recap in
1953 the CIA helped orchestrate a coup
to depose Iran's democratically elected
prime minister replacing him with the
Shah who was friendly to the US and to
whom funny story we supplied weapons and
a nuclear reactor the Shah was
overthrown in a revolution in 1979 and
dozens of American diplomats were held
hostage eventually the Ayatollah
Khomeini took power converting the
country to an Islamic theocracy that is
in an insulting ly brief history of the
last 60 years alone and there is a lot
that I've left out there but if you do
want to learn more just subscribe to my
new podcast talking Tehran with John
Oliver and james van der beek is just a
small taste of it let's pick up where we
left off with the privatization of
state-owned enterprises in Iran you're
talking about the work of Rafsanjani no
no I'm not talking about that John you
do this every time I'm talking
about the underappreciated roles of
moderates like Nettie buzzer oh please
find a big thumping on again about
moderates like Mac D buzzer gunshots
erection they never thought they
deserved raphson Johnnie was a glory
I'll tell you we got the backing of
moderates he was nothing you should
agree we need an ad for MailChimp right
now okay okay
John do you send a lot of mass emails
it's a pretty good podcast it's pretty
good and and look if you didn't know
that james Van Der Beek was an expert in
Iranian history expand your expectations
of what people are capable
but the point is in many Americans Minds
Iran's image is now reduced to a place
where US flags are set on fire and
whether a chance of death to America and
the truth is that is still part of
Iranian political culture much of the
power in the country is held by
conservative clerics who forced
religious compliance at home and pursue
an aggressive foreign policy abroad they
are widely believed to be supporting the
Houthi rebels in Yemen and Bashar
al-assad in Syria and are a major funder
of the terrorist group Hezbollah and the
current Ayatollah is still saying stuff
like this and sure I love the tall fury
by God's favor and grace nothing called
the Zionist regime will exist in the
region by twenty five years from now
okay so it's not the most important part
there but the country's name is Israel
not the Zionist regime if you're gonna
make appalling threats against a nation
at least get their name right I'm sure
that you would not like it if I called
Iran holds papac Harmony's palace of
Persians would you know you wouldn't
like it you wouldn't like it at all but
the truth is that is only part of the
picture of Iran there's also a large
educated relatively liberal middle class
among whom opinions of America tend to
be considerably more positive you can
see it in the fact that they have
knockoffs of American restaurants
they're called mash Donald's ZFC and
pizza hats which are obviously direct
ripoffs of marsh Donald's zfg and pizza
how and Iran's current president Hassan
rouhani is relatively moderate by
Iranian standards even going so far as
to tweet a few years back I wish all
Jews especially Iranian Jews a blessed
Rosh Hashana and when an Iranian leader
begins a statement with the words I wish
all Jews and actually sticks the landing
you kind of have to hand it to him there
and pro-western views are particularly
pronounced among young people born after
the Revolution in fact a few years back
Thrasher Magazine my favorite skateboard
magazine did a story on Iranian
skateboarding culture which has thrived
despite one considerable obstacle Iran
as under sanctions right now and it's
really hard for them to impor
thing from the West this kind of put the
skaters in a position where they were
actually forced to figure out a way to
make their own words we saw one kids
getting a board made of solid steel
which is kind of crazy it's an Iranian
skateboard it's made of metal sick deck
bra although if it was me I'd double up
on the grip tape on my top sheet so we
don't slam gonna go sketchy on the nose
grind I do hope you enjoyed that joke
because it took one of my writers 50
minutes on the skateboarding
Wikipedia page to research it but that's
true but don't those sanctions actually
want one of the reasons that the Iran
deal happened in the first place because
after the international community
discovered that Iran was secretly
building up a nuclear program it was
understandably concerned and imposed
crippling sanctions affecting every part
of Iran's economy from oil to plane
parts to banking and investment one key
motivator in Iran coming to the table to
negotiate was relaxing some of those
sanctions and they got that all the
partners in this deal the US Britain
France Germany the EU Russia and China
agreed to lift specific sanctions on
Iran so that's what Iran got out of this
deal I guess the question is what did we
get and the answer to that is quite a
lot it requires Iran not to enrich
uranium to weapons-grade for 15 years to
reduce its number of operating nuclear
centrifuges from 19,000 to just over
5,000 and to increase the time it would
take to make a bomb from a few months to
a year it's true and those would be
concessions from Iran the deal required
them to reduce their stockpile of
uranium by 98% and mandated that they
would not enrich uranium above three
point six seven percent which is
significantly lower than the 90% needed
for weapons and try to make a bomb at
under four percent enrichment is like
trying to get drunk off a single can of
PBR you can't it cannot be done there's
no way to do it not unless
you're a gerbil and even then only if
you're drinking on an empty stomach
and look that that's not all the deal
also had strict conditions for
monitoring and verification to make sure
that they were in compliance and if they
weren't we could snap those sanctions
back it was a pretty good deal and yet
many felt it was too generous to Iran
Benjamin Netanyahu called it a bad
mistake of historic proportions and here
in the u.s. there was a hard opposition
with ads like this
[Music]
Wow
that is a hostile way to make your point
there is only one ad that you could
completely justify being interrupted by
a nuclear explosion and it is this one
[Music]
[Applause]
good I'm glad those children are dead
but but for all the talk over here about
Iran getting everything they wanted you
should know that Iranian hardliners were
furious arguing that they had given up
way too much Iran's lead negotiator was
this guy javad zarif and some chilling
cell phone footage emerged of him being
confronted by a member of the iranian
parliament and just listened to what was
said to him if Isis comes to our country
you will be the first to take the blow
that is both scary and honestly not
really consistent with how Isis operates
they generally don't come to a country
and say okay nobody dies until we find
that first guy nobody kills anyone until
that first guy takes the first blow we
do this in order or we don't do it at
all where Isis
let's not come off like crazy people but
but despite all that opposition on both
sides the deal was signed which was a
huge achievement or as Donald Trump
would put it a complete disaster I've
studied this issue in great detail I
would say actually greater by far than
anybody else believe me
Oh believe me and it's a bad deal
okay so let's be absolutely clear here
Donald Trump has never studied anything
in great detail if you asked him what
color his wife's eyes are he would say
34d but firm so so what specifically
does Trump think is wrong with this deal
well he has a number of complaints and
the first has to do with monitoring
their nuclear facilities in terms of you
know surveillance they have the right to
self inspect how about that or their
major the most dangerous they can self
inspect okay so that's just not true
they cannot self inspect the deal allows
for regular monitoring of all declared
nuclear sites one of which even has
24-hour video surveillance and it's done
by the International Atomic Energy
Agency the UN's nuclear watchdog which
has already confirmed ten successive
times that Iran is complying with the
deal and fun fact if Iran complies just
once more they win a free meal at Pizza
hat so that's just an extra little fun
incentive for them to stay in line and
that is not the only thing that Trump
gets wrong about the deals inspection
process how about this
we see something wrong or we think
there's something wrong so we have to
wait 24 days before we go in but before
the 24 days start there's a whole
procedure so who knows how long it could
be could be six months okay so what he's
talking about there is the fact that
while again inspectors have constant
access to their declared sites they also
get access to any other site military or
civilian where they suspect undeclared
nuclear activity now Iran can push back
on those suspicions but once the IAEA
demands access Iran has just 24 days max
to let them in and it is a pretty tall
order to completely clean up every trace
of an isotope with a half-life of 710
million years in just 24 days think
about it that's not even long enough to
adequately clean your apartment after
you rent it out on air B&B how is there
Jesus inside my piano
what monster would do this this isn't an
accident
it must be why they wanted a piano but
but but one of trumps other complaints
is that some parts of this deal expire
in 10 or 15 years and as he sees it that
leads to an obvious problem the bigger
problem is that they can keep the terms
and still get the bomb by simply running
out the clock again that is simply not
true they can't keep the terms and get
the bomb the terms expressly forbid them
from doing that what Iran could do in
theory is wait for parts of the deal to
expire in 10 years then it could ramp up
its nuclear program
getting it closer to a bomb but here's
the thing if the deal blows up Iran
could start doing that right now in zero
years and zero is less than 10 trust us
we ran the numbers on this ourselves I
spent a week at kangra speaking with the
location chair of mathematics Michael
Cates and and I feel virtually certain
zero is less than 10 also you should
know before the deal Iran had enough
enriched uranium to eventually create
eight to ten bombs which remember they
gave up meaning they currently have
enough for zero bombs which again is
less than ten I cannot stress enough the
extent to which 0 is less than 10 it
just is we have to agree on that or
we're all and look it is
important to remember this deal isn't
just between the u.s. and Iran there are
multiple countries involved none of whom
are anxious to change its terms even
Britain's Boris Johnson a man who looks
like what would happen if Draco Malfoy
got an MBA and developed a drinking
problem even he thinks a renegotiation
is a non-starter I don't think anybody
has come up with a better idea near
think it's on incumbent on those who
will pose the jcpoa really too to come
up with that better solution exactly you
can't just be against something without
having any plan for what comes next
Trump is like a cat on an airplane
trying to escape from its carrier okay
but if you get out then what do you have
a cat sized parachute in there with you
what's your plan here
obviously I'm not gonna say capsized
parachute without showing you a cat in a
parachute that is just a given I
wouldn't do that to you
and look what Wall Trump has articulated
broadly what he wants some of his
demands are complete non starters he
wants a ban on ballistic missile testing
unconstrained access to any military
sites and no expiration of any clause in
the agreement ever and if those are
deal-breakers for him this deal is
broken and what you would hope that
someone would talk him round Trump has
surrounded himself with Iran Hawks his
nominee for Secretary of State is Mike
Pompeo who's reportedly said of Iran we
know they're cheating we're just not
seeing it which is a hell of a statement
from a guy who gives rim jobs to
guerillas and short-short sure no one
has ever seen Mike Pompeo giving a real
job to a gorilla but that's how we know
he does it think about it and even more
worrisome is john bolton his new
national security adviser bolton is a
far-right conservative who Donald Trump
had originally considered for the job in
2016 but reportedly hesitated because of
his walrus style mustache and I've got
to say I agree with Trump on that one
that moustache is a huge problem he
looks like he's possessed by the ghost
of Borat the point is the point here is
Bolton has long been a critic of the
Iran deal I think the deal is inherently
flawed I think it's a strategic debacle
for the United States
you can always tinker around the edges
and the question is whether putting
lipstick on a pig is really going to
make a difference here come on
this deal is preventing Iran from
getting nuclear weapons it's not a pig
with lipstick besides pigs don't need
lipstick to look beautiful you
superficial these are beautiful
just the way they are I think you need
to conform your completely unrealistic
standards of farm animal beauty hashtag
22nd
both of us gone much further than that
remember that ad with the exploding
family his group made that ad and if
you're wondering well what's his
alternative to an Iran deal it can't be
war with Iran can it well just watch
this speech that he gave to a group of
Iranian dissidents in Paris last year
the declared policy of the United States
of America should be the overthrow of
the mullahs regime in Tehran
[Music]
[Applause]
the behavior and the objectives of the
regime are not going to change and
therefore the only solution is to change
the regime itself and that's and that's
why before 2019 we here will celebrate
in Tehran thank you very much
holy to my ears that is the
National Security Advisor calling for
the invasion of Iran before the end of
the year which is so flagrantly horrific
your brain can barely absorb it it's
like the Barefoot Contessa announcing
that she's going to murder and cook her
husband Jeffrey before 2019 at that
point she's been so obvious if no one
actively stops her it's partly on us so
look unless Congress or our European
allies figure out something they can
sell to trump as a fix
it seems that Trump is going to reimpose
sanctions on May 12th and if he does
that this deal could collapse and the
damage of that would be long-term and
potentially irreversible just set aside
the fact that you would alienate a whole
generation of younger Iranians who
support this deal just think about what
this would do to America's credibility
why would North Korea consider signing a
nuclear agreement with us if we just
broke the agreement we signed only three
years ago with Iran and if this deal
dies and Iran receives its nuclear
weapons program it could then start a
nuclear arms race in the Middle East and
the problem here is I can't offer you
much hope there is not really a write
your Congressman solution to this we
could be in serious trouble
because two of trumps top advisors are
like him dead set against this deal and
they're getting backup from Sean Hannity
who showed the president watches so much
advisors refer to him as the shadow
chief of staff Hannity hates this deal
too so there is not really a way for us
to get a moderating voice into this
conversation short of buying time on
Hannity show this week and running an ad
like this
but how are you hey there Donald
sorry for rock your supper I'm a cowboy
don't like pain when I cap and I'm here
to tell you the Iran deal may not be
perfect but it helps restrict Iran's
ability to start making a bomb for at
least 10 years you blow up the deal and
that turns into zero years and if I've
learned one thing from all these years
of cowboying and cathing it's that zero
is way less than 10 that's correct also
you really want to listen to a guy with
a mustache like this
don't do it Donald don't do it
hey does anyone smell gas oh my god the
stove
that ad is scheduled to run during
Hannity in the DC area on fox news this
week where it'll presumably confuse a
lot of people and I'm not saying that
it's going to change anything but at
least we will know that we tried
[Music]
you